voilà c'est la fille dont je te parlais
c'est à ce moment précis que j'ai su que
c'était pour la vie exactement trois ans
étaient déguisés en une équipe hors du
commun je dirais qu'à cet hôpital
c'est quoi ton cocktail préféré jupe
ample mousse avec la peu de vodka
reprises samedi qu'on aille ailleurs
ouais parce que c'est le premier pouvoir
du reste de ta vie
j'adore ces trucs là j'ai attendu trop
longtemps et elle m'a pris dans ses bras
ça fait du bien de se dire qu'on peut
juste être ami avec un garçon
année avery hockey
en fait il se pourrait que ce soit mon
repos d'être seulement je pouvais blanc
une chance mais tout recommencer
différemment quoi enfin être celui
qu'elle veut
on est ok l'année sinon en 2014 ce truc
de tard il réussit à voyager dans le
temps
tu vas bientôt rencontrer l'homme de
terrain et d'un cocktail préféré moi
c'est jus de pamplemousse avec un pote
cas et trois petits tsariste c'est mon
copain est préféré à ben quoi c'est vrai
de pareils dont je t'ai parlé ce matin
je savais déjà que j'étais gosse de
militaires tu l'as pas deviner trc leurs
portes dès à permet à blick sous
vêtements alors que moi je porte bien
des sous-vêtements regarder ce vieux
cow-boy photo nathan alors son aide pour
la meilleure soirée de vérifier hâte de
voir ce que tu me réserve
regarde moi bien je leur fais une fois
ok ça va botter ça va botter
c'est le joker que tu imites la non
c'était pourquoi j'ai perdu le contrôle
je ne sais plus de faire
je me réveille trois ans après chaque
décision que je prends et ses
conséquences
je croyais que rien arriver sans raison
les choses arrivent au hasard de façon
aléatoire mais elle crée des
opportunités et noir et eu à prendre ces
opportunités même de celle que tu as
raté
[Musique]
je
il abandonner ma banque d'avoir ruiné
votre magnifique soirée belge et vous